good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm just
back from a trip to northern Jordan with
UNHCR the UN refugee agency where I got
to know a few of the 635 thousand Syrian
refugees currently living in Jordan and
in the coming weeks I'll be sharing
several of their stories but as today is
International Women's Day I want to
focus on these two girls 12 year old
majeeda and her 10 year old sister Aida
Aida and majeeda arrived at the asrock
refugee camp the day before I met them
but before that they'd spent more than
four months in limbo at the border their
father Avril Magette described the
situation there as cold hunger and
constant thirst that morning they
registered in the camp which involves
everything from iris scans to identify
them to finding an available shelter try
getting a four year old boy to stand
still for an iris scan by the way when I
asked Aida and majeeda sparrin swith the
family's most urgent needs were they
answered only that they wanted the kids
to get into school and this was a theme
among almost every refugee I met the day
before in the Sadri refugee camp I met
with the tiger' group in which girls are
mentored by young women and when I asked
the girls what they wanted most arrium
and Farah both answered immediately when
I asked not had a mother of young
children who volunteers as a teacher
what she wants for her kids she said
Syria used to be a well-educated nation
but the Civil War has changed that Aida
has never been to school she was only
five when the war began majeeda has also
been out of school for many years when I
later asked Aida what she wanted now
that she was safe in the camp
she didn't say electricity or food or
rest she said and while they will be
able to study at the camp it won't be
easy the schools are underfunded which
means that classes only meet for half of
each day and class sizes are often huge
there are sometimes over 75 students in
a primary school classroom nonetheless
school will be welcome I mean for the
past 4 months these kids had to walk 10
kilometers almost every day to find
firewood at the border and before that
they moved around Syria for years trying
to stay safe when I asked Aida if she'd
lost friends in the war she smiled and
nodded and started to try to explain but
then she began to cry I felt terrible
even for having asked the question but
then again I want you to know I want you
to know that there should be another
sister here
and yet I also want you to know that I
eat and majeeda have rich complex lives
that aren't mere tragedies they're
friendly and warm kids and they smiled a
lot especially later in the day when I
visited them in their shelter a small
but safe single room they joked with
each other and played with their little
brothers they talked to their favorite
childhood game a Syrian version of
hide-and-seek and when I asked Aida what
message she would want to share with
American children her age
our interpreter Nita told me she said we
just want to go to school we just want
to have a life this is not such a big
ask of course but it's hard to deliver
the UN refugee agency remains critically
underfunded and Syrian refugees aren't
legally allowed to work in Jordan where
the unemployment rate was already high
even before the crisis so education
isn't the only challenge I mean when I
asked ahead about the unique
difficulties female refugees face she
said Syrian refugees have seen the time
needed for unpaid work from cooking to
cleaning increase dramatically and that
work as elsewhere in the world is
disproportionately done by women kids
are often pulled from school to help
with chores or find whatever paid work
they can that shortens the number of
years of formal education kids receive
and narrows their future career
opportunities and this is what people
mean when they talk about a lost
generation of Syrian youth but of course
they aren't lost because we know where
they are they are here in asrock they
are waiting in desperate conditions on
the border they are in Germany and
Sweden in Lebanon and Turkey and most of
all in Syria and we must help them get
the nutrition shelter and education they
need to grow into a generation that will
help rebuild their country investing in
girls like Aida and majeeda isn't just
good for them it's vital for all of us
we can do this by supporting UNHCR and
their critical and underfunded mission
to support refugees around the world but
we also do it by acknowledging the full
Humanity of refugees as Aida told me we
just want to have a life but you can't
have a life when the world doesn't
accept that you're a person as valuable
as any other when the world treats you
as other or less than we must fight that
dehumanization not least because to see
the humanity and others is to glimpse it
within ourselves Hank I'll see you on
Friday